استشهاد اربعه من الشبان وربما تستطيع ان
تسمع معي عثمان دويه هذه المسيره وهي
فوقنا تماما في هذه الاثناء في هذه
المنطقه تحوم في سماء مدينه جنين ومخيم
جنين كما تشاهدون هذه هي الاجواء الان في
هذه الاثناء هنا في مدينه جنين وفي محيط
مخيمها الشوارع فارغه تماما قوات الاحتلال
دوريات الاحتلال تراجعت من مكان وتقوم في
هذه الاثناء
بجولات ودوريات في محيط المدينه تتحرك في
محيط المدينه وفي عدد من شوارعها لا تبقى
في مكان واحد وذلك نتيجه للاشتباكات ولقاء
القنابل العبوات محليه الصنع التي يقوم
الشبان بالقائها باتجاه قوات الاحتلال
للتصدي لهذا الاقتحام المستمر منذ اكثر من
ثمان ساعات متواصله عثمان ال مسيره التي
نسمع صوتها بشكل واضح وهي تحلق على علو
منخفض قامت
ب اطلاق صاروخ باتجاه البلده القديمه
تحديدا وكان ذلك يعتبر تصعيدا في اطار
العمليات العسكريه والاجتياحات التي
تنفذها قوات الاحتلال في مدينه جنين
ومخيمها هذا الاجتياح هو الاجتياح ال 15م
عشر منذ السابع من اكتوبر وا هو الاقتحام
والاجتياح الاوسع منذ ذاك التاريخ نظرا
لحجم الاليات والدوريات العسكريه التي اتت
الى هذه المدينه والتي ايضا تقوم
ب تسيير دوريات في هذه الاثناء في المدينه
فيما ايضا تقوم الجرافات العسكريه بتنفيذ
عمليات تجريف وتخريب للط اذا سمحت لي فقط
قبل ان
ت اسمح لي ان انوه الى الخبر العاجل عن
سرايا القدس التي تقول انها استهدفت ناقله
جند
واليت عسكريتين صهيونيين بقذائف تاندم في
محور التقدم شرق خان يونس هذا ما قالته
سرايا القدس تفضل حسن كنت تتحدث عن
الجرافات نعم وهنا ايضا في الحي الشرقي
تحديدا هذا الحي الذي يقع هنا خلفي تماما
هو الحي الاساسي الذي تجري فيه الاشتباكات
بين قوات الاحتلال والشبان والمقاومين لا
سما من المنتسبين والمنتمين لكتيبه جنين
وهؤلاء الشبان يقومون بالاشتباك مع قوات
الاحتلال
باستخدام بدايه اطلاق النار باتجاه
الاليات والدوريات وحتى مشاه الاحتلال
اثناء اقتحامهم فيما ايضا يستخدمون عبوات
محليه الصنع هم يصنعونها بانفسهم هؤلاء
الشبان ويلقونها باتجاه اليات ودوريات
الاحتلال هذه الاشتباكات ما زالت متواصله
ونسمع بين الحين والاخر اطلاق النار
باتجاه اليات ودوريات الاحتلال وهو ما كما
ذكرنا ما استدعى ان تنسحب هذه الاليات من
هنا ولكنها تاتي بين الحين والاخر وتتحرك
في المكان وكان لافتا استخدام قوات
الاحتلال في هذا الاقتحام تحديدا اليات
عليها قذائف او عليها رشاشات تقوم بال قاء
واطلاق النار بشكل اوتوماتيكي الي باتجاه
الشبان وعلى هذه الرشاشات ايضا كاميرات
تتحرك ايضا وترصد اهدافها وتقوم باطلاق
النار بكثافه باتجاه الشبان وهو ايضا ما
يزيد من الخطر الكبير على الشبان اثناء
تحركهم ووجودهم في شوارع ال مدينه وهو
ايضا ما كان قد ادى الى استشهاد شبان في
مخيم الفارعه في اقتحام قبل اربعه ايام في
ايضا جنوب جنين تحديدا في محافظه طوباس هي
ممارسات يقوم بها جيش الاحتلال في اطار
اقتحاماتها المتواصله للضفه الغربيه يضاف
اليها ممارسات بحق الفرق الاسعاف وكذلك
المستشفيات